okay now obviously the first thing for
you I'm cheating a little bit just for
the sake of time but you clearly need a
diagram for this like that that's
complicated just looking at it and I
haven't added anything to it at all
the question says a sailing boat sets
out in a race with three legs as shown
first it goes from A to B so it's going
it's going this way right then it goes
from B to C so it finishes on three legs
it comes back it comes back doesn't it
it returns to a starting point
that's the third and final leg okay they
give you all this information it looks
to me like everything has been placed
onto the diagram you can see the 310
degrees the 9.6 the two 17 and the
thirteen point three okay so far so good
let's have a look at the first question
is and this was very similar to how we
went in question 20 how far is be north
of a all right here's your diagram how
far is be north of a so I'm going up my
time I'm going up I'm going to extend
this a little bit so that North goes all
the way do you see it okay so now I'm
gonna draw an East line over here
like that so this is a North line this
is a nice life okay so if I put that
point there let's call that P the point
which is the distance that will give me
the answer to the question how far B is
north of a which distance give it a name
which one can you see the name if this
is a that's been this is P ap perfect
this distance that's a bad color to
choose this distance here is how far
north is being from a so now that you
know where you're looking what kind of
information
am I gonna need to get that I need an
angle the angle that I need I'm just
gonna make that a bit smaller counseling
the way the angle I need is the one
that's inside the triangle right I think
the one I'm after is this one how do I
find that angle
yeah I'm 360s all the way around I know
that this part over here is 310 so the
left over is 50 okay now that I'm in
this right angle triangle and then one
of the angles I know the side I Martha
so I want this AP over here
b.p I already know so which ratio
Patricia cos is adjacent on hypotenuse
so I can write on the slip'n in down
here cause of 50 degrees is going to be
a pee on 9.6 now just a quick note you
saw how I labeled I drew these lines
I called that point P you don't have to
do that
but I'm gonna have a lot of other points
in this diagram and I want to be able to
give things names so I'm not confusing
myself and I'm communicating clearly to
the marker so I highly recommend you do
something like that the next one will be
Q and X on me so therefore I can
multiply both sides by 9.6 and that will
give me the length that I'm off done
happy if someone got it six point two
I'm pretty happy with that
okay yep all right you they didn't ask
you a series of other questions that are
very similar
you just got to think about the way
you're gonna do your constructions this
next one how far is C south of B all
right where am I gonna have to construct
how far is C
yeah very good so I'm gonna go up from C
so there's all right that so long as I
go past me I'm okay and then I guess I'm
gonna go west from babe yeah did I do
that line straight straight enough okay
so I've got a new point here I'm gonna
call that Q you're just gonna go in the
alphabet which length do I want give it
its got a name it's got a name CQ right
CQ this is the one that is how far see
you south of big again you're gonna need
an angle inside that triangle which
angle do right it's got again it's got a
name it's got a name this one here
that's the angle I won right that's the
easiest angle I can see I think that's
cbq yeah are you asking why isn't
betting or why is it that name yeah
correct so when you when you name an
angle like this cbq right I'm basically
going in order C then B then Q so I'm
going around the ankle QBC saying yeah
QB see I said well they're both having
be in the middle which is the important
part I think people tend to do them
alphabetically though but that's not so
easy
okay what's CP q how do I work out its
size yeah very good so if I went all the
way around this way to West that would
be 270 we actually looked at that than a
previous question but I'm not going that
far I've got this 217 that's the
difference so
fifty-three to 70 minus 217 I think is
53 isn't it I'm not gonna rehearse this
now in terms of the number but you can
see I want this side over here which is
opposite the angle I know this leg 13.2
which is the which side is it in this
triangle
it's the hypotenuse to opposite and
hypotenuse is same very good so sine of
c PQ is going to be opposite which I
don't know on hypotenuse which I do know
okay and then you can go ahead and you
can work out that value okay okay how
are you faring is the approach make
sense yeah you can see I construct I
look at where where the triangle is in
there for what angle I need inside and
then you just have to be careful with
okay how do I work out the sizes of the
Daniels okay do you want me to keep
going
or do you want to have a go based on
that start hands up for keep going
alright what is the C south of a okay
sure so just like I did for the last two
parts I need to make a triangle here C
and he's a so where's the triangle going
to be
yeah I have to go south day nice so let
me just move this guy out of the way I
have to go southeast this way and then I
have to go east
okay so I've made a new triangle I've
got these points intersecting and
another these lines intersecting the
viewpoints I'm gonna call that bar
that's you I would find out how far see
is south of a what's the name of the
side that is how far sees Saturday where
is it yeah er is perfect it's uh this
guy over here do you see it okay let's
think this one's a bit trickier how am I
going to find out the angle or an angle
inside this triangle
hmm this is trickier this is I'm glad
someone asked me to keep going
look carefully
okay I'm actually going to pass through
this is actually a really important
stage for you guys because I can tell
you the answer right now
and then you will learn nothing you'll
just learn what the number is which is
useless to you next time okay unless
you're going to pause for a minute
you've got the diagram there so do i I
want you to stop looking at this
I want you look at your diagram made to
draw some things rub out some things
think slowly carefully talk to your
friends how can you work out any angle
in this triangle down here that's the
question that I got where okay you have
a thing a RC
yes
by the way I want to give you a bit of a
clue before before you say anything
right one of the tricky things is this
is the way I said you know when you have
to if you're walking driving a very
short distance right like if you went
from here to cherubic village okay if
you're driving it's pretty much like one
way to go right I mean unless you want
to take the really scenic route there's
one part whereas if I ask you you're
somewhere very far away there's like
five six seven ten different ways to
drive okay now this is a question that
it's not close it's a question that's
far away we've got all this work here
there are lots of different ways to
approach the question now I've asked you
a couple of questions that would suggest
for this and this question I needed to
find an angle to find a length I found
an angle then I found a way in this case
down here you've hit some trouble in
terms of finding an angle to find this
length is there anything else you could
do if this was the length that you
wanted if you think you have an answer
I'll come around to you cuz I don't
spoil it do you remember as I went
through I kept making triangles but they
weren't just any triangles those special
triangles why are they special there all
right angle because there's like north
and east and south and west all that
kind of thing I want you to look at all
the right angles I've drawn I drew one
over here then I drew one over here the
last one I drew was over here down in
the bottom right-hand corner if those
are right angles then this is a right
angle too isn't it
so what kind of shape is the whole thing
it's a rectangle right now you've
already worked out that this is 6.2 and
I think some of you worked out this
angle this length as well didn't you but
in a rectangle the opposite side thank
you ten point five in a rectangle the
opposite sides are equal to each other
so this final length over here is just
the difference ten point five take away
six
- that sounds like 4.3 to me